THEY'VE SUFFERED BACK-TO-BACK
LOSSES IN REGULATION FOR THE
FIRST TIME THIS YEAR.
JASON SPEZZA THROWS IT BACK IN .
HANIFIN ON IT NOW.
LONG TIME BETWEEN WHISTLES HERE
IN THE FI
TO THE POINT TO RROSS IS ZADORO.
MARNER AT CENTRE ICE.
KYLINGTON .
HE SHOOTS.
THAT WAS BLOCKED.
REBOUND.
DUBE SHOOTSHERE WITH ZADOROV --A
GAME.
HE HAS A GOOD SHOT.
VLADAR WAVES IT BACK.
WHO, BY THE WAY, IN THE WORLD
WITH TAVARES.ONSHIP
MARNER IN!
SHOOTS!
PENALAL
MARNER PASSED AT IT.
KEPT ALIVE BY ANDERSSON.
DOWN TO HOLL FOR NYLANDER.
MATTHEWS DRIFTING WIN
THE 50// AWAY.
NYLANDE
MARNER BACK ON IT.
BACKHAND SHOT.
SAVE MADE.GETS
UP FROM BEHIND THE GOAL LINE YOU
KNOW IT'S BEEN A
THAT'S PICKED UP BY KYLINGTON.
HE COMES JUMPING AHEAD WITH
GAUDREAU.
GAUDREAU TOGO WITH JOHNNY
GAUDREAU'S 11th ASSIST OF THE
YEAR   ZONE.
S
HIS AVERAGE ON THE SEASON.
TEES S
IT.
PINBALLS ON A COUPLE LLP GOALTER
THE CALG NIGHT.
HE TAKES THIS
PENALTY KILLING IS SEVENTH.
GAUDRDR
HANIFIN SWINGS BACK. TH OVERTIME
MATTHEWS.
AUSTON MATTHEWS IN THE BREAK.KY.
MOVES IN AND SHOOTS.
WHAT A PAD SAVE BY CA RIELLY.
MATTHEWS WORKS IN, FIRES,
SCORES.
AUSTON MATTHEWS, OVERTIME
WINNER!